[Music]
good afternoon everyone
I'm Maggie I'm Adam Powell and I'm gem
all right and we're here to talk about
UI patterns funny a lot of you are
interested in that suddenly so the talk
was kind of that there was a stealth
title for the talk so obviously it's
about jetpack compos on next generation
UI talkie that we're working on and it's
available in open source and so we want
to talk a little more about this today
but first we want to talk to you a bit
of this story and explain why we're
doing this
so how did you get here a lot of you
obviously are familiar with views and
activities and fragment and I'm sure
you'll love those api's they are close
to perfect so just to give you a little
bit of background so this is a diagram
that Chet did for a talk that we gave I
think last year shows you a timeline of
what we've been up to especially on the
Android toolkit team so after we shipped
Android 1.0 we didn't do anything for
many many years
and then we finally woke up and decided
to you know write new libraries to help
you so things like recyclerview
constraint layout art components and of
course we had the adoption of caffeine
so we have been working on new things
but one things we one thing we never
changed was the UI toolkit itself we did
a lot of work underneath to make it
better we had hardware acceleration we
fixed some bugs we added some bugs we
added a few features but we never
changed it fundamentally so one of the
things that happened you know over ten
years ago was this this is a device we
call the sooner and this was the first
device that I used to write Android code
when I joined Google so to give you an
idea this device had a single CPU
running that running at 80 megahertz
it didn't have a GPU we had 64 Meg's of
RAM and the screen was 320 by 240 this
was not the first device we shipped
which is the g1 which was slightly
better but there was no similar in
spirit which shipped with the GPU we
mostly didn't use it so I had talked it
was pretty much design for this device
fast forward a few years and now we have
this kind of devices so this is a pixel
- I believe and the screen resolutions
now are 21 60 60 by 1080 or
for 2960 by 1440 on the excel variants
and here you can see a screenshot of the
Sooner at the same scale and it fits
comfortably over just one icon on the
launcher so you know where you're still
using the same UI toolkit so maybe twice
time to rethink our approach to you is
to better serve those devices and on top
of that so we we build the architecture
components over the past couple years
and the approach we took was extremely
interesting we were more open open we
did a lot of alphas and betas in our C's
we talked with you the community a lot
to hear what you wanted from us
I mean you build the applications we
don't really anymore so we need your
input to know what it is you need what
is you want what are the times that
you're facing every day so yeah what are
you asking for and what would you like
to do what would you like us to do so
when we ask this question for the
battery for the UI talk it in particular
one of the answers we got was unbundle
the UI toolkit because until now every
time we wanted to ship a fix in the UI
toki Tori what time we wanted to ship a
new feature we could do this easily
ourselves but then you had to wait for
just a few years to be able to read
tourism in API level and I know I've had
many discussions personal with some of
you where I said hey I fixed your bug
you like yeah I don't care because you
know the fix is not going to reach my
users devices for a long long time so
not helpful I don't
so we're thinking about moving some of
our widgets to jetpack you know make
them be a support library let's take
textview move it entirely in jetpack and
then you won't be able to there are
fixes but as we were thinking about
doing this doing this we've thought well
if we're gonna do this how about we
start improving those widgets a little
bit what could we do to improve the
api's and you know I'm sure you all love
the API of our UI toolkit but as chet
put it API design is building future
regrets and we have a lot of regrets a
lot even more than you do here are some
examples so for instance view Java
do you know how big it is I'm sure you
have big files in your source code I'm
pretty sure you don't have files as big
as this one so we have almost 30,000
lines of code
in Judah Java yeah that is Google scale
right here
to be fair it's a lot of comments but
still this is no not very good design so
that's one thing and then there's random
stuff for instance spinner why do we
have this class called spinner it's a
combo box or drop-down we don't like
spinner nobody does and a bunch of us
why is it called spinner I'll show you I
so when we shipped our first SDK this is
what it look like so I ran this on on my
Mac and it does spin so we're not
entirely crazy or stupid we just changed
our mind
another example that I really like is a
button button if you look at the source
code of button the Java it's extremely
interesting there's very few lines of
code in there because it extends
textview why it's a good question
because when you need to display text
the problems that text you can do a lot
of things for instance you can make a
button selectable if you want and I'm
pretty sure you can also make it
editable alright and of course there are
tons of other issues but Adam is gonna
talk more about those yeah Ramon told me
that I had to take the slide that
started with fragments here I'm not
entirely sure why so as you stop to
factor some of your you eyes on Android
and you start to have to make some
decisions about how you're going to
write your UI components and this is a
question that we've had a lot over the
years do I write a fragment or do I
write a custom view or a custom view
group and the problem with this is that
the answer can be really different
depending on the kind of component that
you're writing and each approach has
some of its own challenges for example
if you see this line of code somewhere
because someone decided that they were
going to write a custom view to solve a
particular problem what exactly is your
first reaction awesome
Noro mom no ok so custom views are kind
of daunting to write because you really
have to get so many things right
especially if you want to expose a first
class at API surface you've got
properties that need their getters and
setters pretty standard stuff you've got
XML attributes which means that you need
to start adding
more stuff in your adders XML defined
style obols
speaking of styles you need to define
actual default Styles and probably edit
some default theme attributes to make
sure that all those Styles get wired up
properly and that's before you even get
to the sheer volume of code that you
need for dealing with things like layout
or touch events so meanwhile fragments
give you a whole lot of flexibility but
plus all the lifecycle hooks for hanging
your application logic from especially
now that you've got arch components to
give you some of this in a more
pluggable way but this kind of makes
them better suited for coarser grained
situations reusable hold article
displays with interactive sub components
and not really so much things like
single buttons but the problem with this
is that your apps aren't static they
really change and grow over time so
there's a potentially really high
engineering cost to having to cross over
from one of these abstractions to
another as your use cases change so you
insulate yourself from that change you
build other architectures to keep your
views your fragments and activities is
removed from these things as possible
and maybe actually make it a little bit
easier to test along the way no matter
which of these architectures or some of
them that aren't listed that you might
choose you they all take on the same
basic shape you bind some of this stuff
in your activity your views publish
events and receive State and everything
in between is kind of a judgement call
so these architectures really exists to
help define and reason about your apps
data flow and answer the three main
questions so what is the source of truth
who owns it and more specifically who
can change it so once you answer some of
these questions then you realize that
the Android UI toolkit doesn't really
work this way views kind of owned their
own State and make their own changes
whether you want them to or not
most of these view state changes at
least have some optional listeners that
you can attach so you can respond to
some of those changes and do something
about it but really the spinner is
another great example here as odd as it
is and
it's got this on selected item change
listener that tells you when the user
changed the value you've picked a new
value from the drop-down and it gives
you this call back after the items
already changed and for a lot of you
eyes this is kind of useless because
then you have to change it back after
the fact so if you've ever created one
of those UI is where you have a custom
dot dot dot you pop up a dialog you let
the user make some custom selections and
then you have to change the adapter set
the value to something new it's kind of
a song-and-dance that's not a lot of fun
and you also have to deal with this idea
of these reentrant listener calls once
you do set something back so your
listener has to handle both the cases
where you meant to change it on purpose
or when the user did it and that just is
more and more code that you can get
wrong but you know then there's some
advantages to this kind of approach I
mean like I would love to just be able
to change my salary and then tell Romo
about it after the fact we'll talk about
it that's work no this is me telling you
after the fact about it okay so speaking
of events when you have a single source
of truth you don't have all of these
problems every piece of state has one
owner and only the owner can make
changes to that particular State so that
means that the owner is listening to
events that are happening somewhere else
in the UI and it makes changes in
response how many of you have seen some
code like this hopefully not too
recently oh no we've got a few hands
okay so Android UI API is were really
kind of designed for this world handling
events by implementing several different
listener interfaces in one class where
that state lives by implementing these
interfaces where the state is you can
make sure that you don't have to lace
that state through too many different
places and you know this is kind of
gross but lambdas weren't even part of
the language when this was common
practice so we can take a few liberties
here but if you let somebody who's
comfortable with Kotlin loose they might
go nuts and play some golf they might
write something more like this and you
know the advantages of something like
this is that it's event-driven
and it's built on composing behaviors
rather than based on inheritance you can
kind of get away with implementing a
bunch of interfaces on a central class
like the slide we saw before when you
have a small team if everybody fits in
the same room and you can just ask each
other questions you know that you're not
going to make a mess in front of one
another but as app and team sizes grew
it became much less sustainable to do
that so by leaning into Kotlin in
particular we can write much more
powerful and more composable api's but
really whether you've decided to write a
fragment or a view the changes that you
have to make really kind of look similar
if you're trying to write something
that's really reusable something that
exposes a first-class API surface for
other people to use you'll have
something that looks either Mike
fragment or my view and it might be a
Kotlin or a Java file you have an XML
file that holds your layout for that
particular file potentially if it's
something complicated if it's something
more than just a simple button that
clicks you've got some stuff in your
adders XML file that defines the style
Bowl and all the different attributes
that it can take and you know yeah also
have to make sure that you don't step on
that shared namespace that resources
work in can't declare two attributes for
two completely different styles if they
have a different type that would be
silly and then finally you have to deal
with everything around styling so you're
spreading all of this code that really
has to do with the same component across
many different files and by breaking
that spatial locality it makes it harder
to regain context or flow at a glance
after you've been interrupted so for
example if you have pets or small
children or an open plan office you
might get interrupted pretty often so
really we're trying to address all of
these things at once so first off we
want to make sure that we unbundle from
the platform releases so that you can
take advantage of what we're working on
immediately we want to make sure that
you have fewer technology stack
flowcharts to traverse when you're
deciding how to build your component we
want to make sure that we're not telling
you well if you're doing something
that's bigger like this start with a
fragment otherwise a button and if
you're not sure yeah flip a coin see how
it goes maybe refactor later
we want to help you clarify state
ownership and event handling this is
really big because this is one of those
things that ends up being almost an
afterthought in some applications if
you're not thinking about it upfront but
it's really the the flow of data through
your application that can be the most
complex interactions and finally we want
to help you just write less code so the
simplest program that you can write in
Kotlin is really really simple so
whenever you're writing a GUI app though
they're not this kind of snapshot in
time it's not a fire-and-forget
construct where you run it once and then
the program terminates you're done it's
done its job so we kind of need to
handle this idea of an event loop and
things that change over time and Kotlin
really gives us some huge advantages for
working with asynchronous code now but
can we go even further can we make it as
simple as this to write an Android app
well maybe we can what if instead of
calling text or in print line we called
text what if calling text would emit a
text widget to the UI hierarchy this is
the idea behind jetpack compose it's a
declarative UI toolkit built for Android
it's inspired by frameworks like react
with Oh view j/s and flutter but it's
written completely in Kotlin and is
fully compatible with the existing
Android view system it aims to simplify
the way that you write code by making
your Android UI hierarchies more
declarative with compose your UI is
defined as a function and this function
transforms data into view hierarchy in
this case the input is a simple piece of
data a person's name and the output is a
UI hierarchy is a text widget when you
need to update the name we can just
reinvention with the new data and the UI
hierarchy will contain a text widget
with the new text this radically
simplifies your application because you
no longer have to have separate code
paths for inflating the initial views
and then updating the views later if we
invoke the function with an appropriate
name then we'll get text hello world on
the screen when the data changes
we can invoke the function again with
the new data and the new data appears
with a new greeting on the screen each
time we invoke the function with
different data the text on the screen is
updated but what exactly is composed and
how does this work among other things
compose is a completely new set of
widgets and toolkit api's built on top
of composable functions they're not
views they're not fragments there's
something smaller more modular easier to
work with and easier to test in
isolation compose is also a cutland
compiler plug-in which makes it possible
to define your own declarative functions
using our declarative API the composed
compiler is what powers the new widget
set and makes it easy for you to define
your own composable widgets compose
widgets are also fully compatible with
the existing view system whether you're
working with Kotlin or the java
programming language we provide ways for
you to use the new widget set in your
existing view hierarchy and you can use
existing views in the compose hierarchy
you can mix and match you can adopt it
incrementally and you can adopt it at
your own pace just like Kotlin itself
it's also very early stage we're still
in active development and we're moving
to a LSP so that you guys can get an
early preview and so that you can be a
part of its development too so we can
collect feedback from you but it's not
ready for production use yet if you did
want to use compose in an application it
might look something like this you can
call it composable up functions directly
from the content of your activity all
compostable functions are annotated with
an ACK composable annotation this tells
the composed compiler that your function
should be treated as a widget and it
allows us to jump in and perform the
necessary rewrites at the right time
we've been working with the JetBrains
team to make all of this possible and
it's still very experimental but
basically we intercept calls to
composable functions and that's what
allows us to provide the declarative API
ultimately these functions are fully
featured Kotlin functions which allows
us to do some really interesting things
for example if we wanted to greet the
user 10 times we could use a simple for
loop to do exactly that if we want to
iterate over a list of names we can
greet a whole bunch of people all at
once we can also have logic to shoku
something completely different when the
list is empty but the most important
thing about composable widgets is that
they're composable compose makes it
trivial to define your own composable
functions and reuse them throughout your
application the UI hierarchy is built by
having composable functions call other
composable functions so our story widget
here uses several stock elements that
we're gonna provide out-of-the-box to
build up a pretty straightforward layout
but you might see another issue here if
you're not suspending disbelief quite
enough looking at our slide we're here
so as we know if that list right there
is really really big then this would
create a whole lot of these Story
widgets that we're not going to see as
Android developers we've been trained
over the years to avoid this in fact I
think about 10 years ago romana I gave
our first talk together where we were
talking about ListView
so this today would be the job of a
recycler view kind of our ListView -
widget that you're all probably familiar
with but that means that we have to
factor out an adapter to handle the
recycler view itself requesting and
rebinding those views so as you probably
know there's really no good way to fit a
recycler view adapter onto a slide it's
a lot of code even in the best case and
I'm using data binding to cheat a bit
here and several things just aren't
shown at all like the diff callback for
helping to handle animations on data set
changes and we certainly don't have
anything about event handling in here
but you kind of get the basic idea
so let's come back to this loop in the
jetpack compose version and see what
else we can do well this is Kotlin after
all we can define a generic composable
function that looks like a foreach loop
by using a trailing lambda argument and
have it emit each story widget as its
asked for so what we did here is we just
defined our recycler view adapter in one
line of code so the implementation of
the scrolling list itself can be just as
smart of it's a recycler view the body
that we pass to a composable function
call can itself be a composable function
lambda so that scrolling list
can choose to call it multiple times or
not at all
much more powerful than just passing
parameters through an include tag since
it means the scrolling list doesn't need
to know anything about what we're going
to put in there when we use it you can
put entirely different structures in
here just depending on code that you're
running and defining so we can do some
other kind of neat things too we can
offer some really powerful hooks into
our runtime for life cycle and
subscription management that can work
together seamlessly with things like
live data rx Java or the new Kotlin
flows so up until now we can do most of
what we shown here just with a clever
DSL but here observe will return a new
value each time it changes and cause the
newsfeed function around it to run again
so that'll feed new data to our
scrolling list much like a recycler view
a data herd recyclerview adapter data
swap will so observe as shown here is
just a find in library code there's
nothing special here there's nothing
that we've implemented that's based on
internal API you can write your own - if
you have your own favorite observable or
callback types so what else does this
imply about how the scrolling list must
work so let's go ahead and put it into
something a little bit more
sophisticated so we saw with observing a
live data that we can trigger a
recomposition when something changes so
let's use an async loading function that
can give us a placeholder immediately
but the result of running some sort of
lazy loaded block once it's actually
completed so all of these sorts of
complex image loading scenarios that
we're all familiar with suddenly becomes
something very simple that we can use
anywhere and also like we saw with the
scrolling list we can weave data across
layers of the hierarchy and they don't
have to be direct tree children either
it doesn't matter what kind of Chrome or
how many layers of hierarchy that that
card or column might add in between in
order to do their work so we can go
further than we can with something like
data binding and we can write a whole
lot less wire up code we can just use
the lexical scope of that image or story
that we already have and we can refer to
the story headlines several layers deep
this is really part of what helps make
composable functions composable how
they're kind of getting their name we
can leave this as is
I mean it's a lot of code for a slide
but it's not a lot to glance at at an
editor or we can just use our normal
tools that we've got highlight it
extract method on any part of it and go
ahead and generalize it this isn't
anything magic it's just the same tools
and techniques that we're already used
to doing when we're writing code so
we've talked about how we can observe
changes in live data and we've seen how
we can show placeholders while we
request a data load from somewhere else
but what if we get an update to one of
our story data objects so our story data
that we used as a parameter in there is
really most naturally represented as a
Kotlin data class there's really nothing
too special about it but we'd like to be
able to update our UI if anything about
it changes what if this was mutable so
if it were a fragment we might use an
arch components view model with some
live data as as properties and use the
same technique that we saw earlier but
this is going to get really repetitive
really quickly especially with all that
extra subscription management we're kind
of deciding where all this goes really
we just wanted to write that code from
the last slide and you can so composers
compiler plug-in lets you mark a data
class as a model which will make the
properties observable when it's used in
a compose function now if our story
changes the story wedge widget that read
its fields will know to recompose the
compose runtime observes the changes and
will cause the story widget function to
rerun and update our UI with the new
data
when you're generalizing your code like
that it's really important to break it
up into multiple compostable functions
and understand how the data flows
through your application the application
passes beta in this case a list of
stories into the news feed the news feed
is then going to iterate over this list
of stories extracting each of the pieces
of Story data from the list and passing
one story data to each story widget the
story widget then reads the title the
image and the content from the story
data the important thing here is that
the parent is always in control of the
data for the child if the data needs to
be shared between multiple widgets the
data should be hoisted up to a common
ancestor and passed down to each of the
widgets that needs it children should
not be reading from global variables or
global data stores they should be
side-effect free and should not do
anything except what the parent tells
them to do as your application scales
this architecture makes your code much
easier to reason about but what happens
if the application wants to know when a
user clicks on a story one interesting
pattern is to pass lambdas down because
code is data which allows us to have
events propagate upwards it looks
something like this in this case the
news feed takes an unselected lambda
which is going to take in some story
data which is the current story it will
then when these news feed invokes the
story widget it's going to take this
lambda and create a new lambda of its
own and pass that lambda to the story
widget the story widget then passes that
lambda to a clickable widget which will
respond to the click when a user clicks
on this story clicks on the clickable
widget the unclick will fire which will
cause the event to propagate back up to
the lambda that was created and passed
in this lambda will call unselected
which is the lambda that was passed to
the news feed by the application so the
parents is always in control the data in
this case a lambda has been passed down
and then the event bubbles back up if we
look at this in diagram form we see that
the application starts with some data
passes it down to the news feed which
passes it down to each of the story
widgets which in turn passed the
information down to
the compostable building blocks that
build up each widget then when a user
clicks on a piece of the widget that
triggers an event which calls the
lambdas going back up with a hierarchy
back up to the screen ultimately the
application can then update the
applications data model and the new data
will be passed back down all the way
down until it's displayed onto the
screen notice that the data was always
passed top down and data always consumed
as parameters the widget didn't have to
reference the activity it didn't do
anything except code that was controlled
by the parent we'll come back to this
with the spinner example that's right
so the spinner has a problem that the
code that we just saw doesn't and that
the spinner makes you deal with multiple
sources of truth so our app has a state
the spinner has a state and the spinner
doesn't ask us before letting the user
change its state and it's the basic
shape of the problem and there's two
ways to solve this when when you have
this like one of these sides must win if
you want to have a single source of
truth so we could design some of these
components such that the spinner itself
is the source of truth and you could see
how you would put that together even
with the API that we just saw and it
basically looks like having to add a
whole bunch of validation api's it means
that every user interaction which it
needs these fully-formed api's for
anything that you can change to sort of
filter through what you might do in
order to validate that what the users
inputting is actually correct and it
scales kind of poorly if you're writing
those components yourself you want to
have a case where you where it's Turtles
all the way down you want to make sure
that it's as easy to write a component
as it is to consume a component so you
kind of don't want everybody to have to
deal with writing all their api's twice
writing these sort of validation filters
for every property that you can set so
the other option that we think is better
that we're certainly pitching here is to
let the app own its own data and have
the apps backing data model the source
of truth that you're using that's part
of your data repository be the source of
truth instead so this has a whole lot of
other advantages
let's take a look at a concrete example
here we have a food preferences widget
that we define as a compostable function
it takes in some user preference data
and ultimately it will emit a spinner
which has some set of options that are
available to the user
notice that the spinners data is set by
the selected parameter so the food
favorite food of the user is passed
directly to the spinner the parent
widget in this case food preferences is
in control of what the spinner is
showing and when this spinner has a user
indicate that they want to make a change
the user can then execute the unchanged
code which will result in the data being
updated the spinner doesn't know which
data is being updated or what to do it
just calls unchanged when the data does
get updated this compose function will
get recomposed
and the new selected value will be set
we can apply the same approach to text
so in this case we have an editable text
for the users name and all that the
unchanged handler does is set the name
this looks pretty generic and you might
wonder why the editable text couldn't
just set the text itself but maintaining
this one-way data flow allows us to do
some really interesting things for
example if we have a phone number
preferences then when a new potential
value comes in we can do filtering we
can invalid any invalid characters and
then we can format the phone number so
that it looks nice when the user is
typing it in and then we set the data
model to the new formatted phone number
again this will trigger a recomposition
which will cause the editable text to
show the new value all right so let's go
ahead and go back to some of our goals
from the beginning that we listed
through did we actually meet some of
those goals and I kind of think we did
so in order to meet our unbundling goals
we're open sourcing a new UI API and
component set for jetpack we've offered
composable functions that scale across
these layers of abstraction a composable
function can do the same sorts of jobs
as a fragment or as a custom view group
or even as something as small as a
single button
we've kind of established this guideline
of one way observable data flow as a
first class concept and we're building
the system to make it easy to sort of
stay on this happy path and finally you
have less code and you can keep it in
one place you don't have to split your
focus across multiple files just to
write a piece of your UI okay that was a
lot of information in one short talk and
we're only just scratching the surface
some of you looked excited and others
might have a lot of questions for
example what about view compatibility
will this work with the existing views
in like how do i integrate this into my
application so one of the things that
you can do is have a annotation that
indicates that this code should be
usable from within a Android view and
when you do that it'll generate a view
class this class is just a standard view
like any other from your composable
function it and you can use it from xml
as shown below or you can call the find
view by ID and get a reference to the
node and pass data directly to the view
you can also yeah there's other things
that might be interesting to you for
example we've been giving a lot of
thought to how layout editor and preview
tool would work if you're giving a lot
of thought to animation Styles themes
and constraint layout all of these
things are really important to get right
before we go with a stable release and
so we're gonna make sure that we have
support for everything that you would
need to build beautiful applications and
we're still thinking about a lot of
other things we're continuing this
exploration we have ideas around
multi-threaded layout around
asynchronous parallel execution of
composable functions around memoization
and much more all of these things become
feasible because of the declarative
programming model and we encourage you
to start exploring these ideas with us
we'd love to hear your ideas alright I
just want to make one clarification you
saw an example jetpack compost that was
using a spinner we don't have a spinner
yet and it won't be called spinner so
that was just you know
how are people going to understand what
you use but if you really want one you
can build one that's the whole point
yeah so just so like I just want to
reiterate that here one of the key
elements is well toukyo means that every
live first composition if you go look at
the source code in ASP you can look at
how some of the widgets were implemented
and you'll see they are dead simple when
you still have to write some code but
should I get the check box for instance
it's just a few lines of code and
everything each user is available to you
to create your own the only way data
flow model is also really important
because a lot of the bugs and a lot of
it'll burn up late in your code comes
from trying to keep two data models in
sync at all time and M is that up all
the time and I'm sure you do as well so
we just got rid of the pollen all
together so that that Campos is not
ready to ship yet we've established that
please go take a look at the source code
if you go to d dot android.com slash
jetpack campos we have explanations we
have a readme that explain how to source
trees architectured you can run a
special version of Android studio that
will let you play with it compile it we
have a few demos that are available you
can look at the entire source tree but
in the meantime you can get ready before
this becomes available so one thing you
can do is just play with it but you can
also try to structure your application
to try to fold this one way the airflow
model so one thing you can do already is
try to eliminate all the fun you bodies
you have because every time you do this
it's almost the code smell especially if
you called get on a view that means
you're trying to synchronize the data
model of the view with the data model of
your application and this is a potential
source of bugs and you won't be able to
do this anymore
in jetpack compos because your functions
are composable so just emit a new tree
at no point can you get a handle on the
actual you know not physical but the
actual new view object that will be put
on screen so you need to get rid of this
habit like basically right now also you
can start working at architectural
components how many of you are using the
art components in one form or another
all right you are all awesome everybody
who didn't raise their hands like run
back to your to your desk and go fix
that please so you have several things
you can use that view model and life
data but there are also other solutions
out there so please try to use those
and now we have a few minutes left so
here's the URL that you can check out if
you want to know more and sure to find
the source tree
[Music]